[Music]
what if the battery in your electric
vehicle could be used to power well
anything and i'm not just talking about
usb charging here i'm talking about
proper power enough to power the
appliances in your home maybe even the
appliances in your neighbor's home well
the idea is called v2x or vehicle to
anything charging and it's actually more
than an idea it's on some cars right now
this is sort of closer than people
realize the ability to technically do
this is there this technology isn't just
changing what our cars can power it
actually has the potential to completely
redefine the relationship between cars
and the energy grid itself let me
explain
okay before we go any further i want to
clear up why you might have heard v2x
called a few different names because the
x part of it changes depending on what
that ev is capable of charging embrace
yourself because it's about to get
pretty acronymy okay so first off
there's v2 l which stands for vehicle to
load and that's where you use your evs
battery to power things that could
normally be plugged in so charging a
laptop or running some power tools next
up is v2v that's where you use your ev
to charge another ev pretty simple and
the last one is v2 h or vehicle to house
or vehicle to home and that's where you
use the battery in your ev to power your
house it could kind of be your backup
generator that's parked in your garage
that's wsj's jennifer hiller who has
been writing about ev charging
technologies if you lose power during a
storm or some kind of emergency and you
need backup power for a few hours or a
couple of days your car battery could be
the source that's exactly what ford is
deploying on its electric f-150
lightning the company says the battery
and the lightning can fully power a home
for three days or run essentials for up
to 10 days now obviously if you use all
the energy in your battery for powering
your home you're not going to be able to
drive anywhere so the company has
developed an app that allows users to
keep some power set aside for the truck
itself ford recently announced it was
working with energy provider pg e to
test how their system interacts with the
grid and pg e have announced a similar
initiative with gm for the company's
ultimate platform and the lightning
isn't the only commercial vehicle to
have this technology both hyundai's
ionic 5 and kia's ev6 also offer v2l
charging according to the company the
ev6 has up to 62 kilowatt hours of power
which the company says is enough power
for a family of four for five days but
there's one acronym i haven't touched on
yet and it's one that could actually
save you money and that's v2g or vehicle
to grid vehicle to grid is the idea that
takes it a step further where you could
provide power from your vehicle that
would feed power onto the electric grid
at large and you would be a little mini
kind of store of energy coming from your
garage the idea is that the grid would
use the battery in your ev to store
energy at times of low demand and it
would then buy that energy back from you
at times of peak demand how much energy
they'd be allowed to take would be
defined by you the user and how much you
get paid for that energy is still very
much up in the air one of the main ideas
of this is if you were getting
compensated it would essentially offset
some of the cost of buying an electric
vehicle some commercial vehicle
manufacturers are already running pilot
tests on v2g charging like porsche who
recently hooked five electric ticans to
the power grid in germany to test how
well the two systems communicated but
jennifer told me it's unlikely we'll
first see widespread v2g adoption in
personal vehicles the first places that
we're seeing the vehicle-to-grid
programs are in
sort of the more commercial space you
know school buses or fleets but there's
a reason why this technology isn't
widely used yet and that's because it's
too early to tell what the effect of all
that charging and discharging will be on
the lifespan of the battery there's a
lot of debate i think about how this
affects battery life what's more many ev
owners may want to hold on to every watt
of power in their batteries after all
according to edmonds range anxiety was
one of the top concerns buyers had when
considering switching to an ev here's
the thing though the iea forecast that
the demand for lithium iron one of the
key ingredients in batteries is set to
increase 40 times by 2040 as the demand
for energy storage increases and with
such a high demand for batteries there's
a strong chance that many of them will
stop becoming single purpose so while
our cars may not be pumping energy back
into the grid just yet it may not be
long before your ev is powering your
neighbor's appliances
hey i didn't have time to cover it in
this video but if you want to see
vehicle to grid in action head over to
uterek in the netherlands they're trying
to become a bi-directional energy city
and if you want to know more about the
future of how we might be getting from a
to b then don't forget to subscribe see
you soon
[Music]